you got the fans on their feet now
not just cheering that's a standing
o with the Breakaway pass to Donado Donado moving
in back shot stop by the court a clear Breakaway
for the former Kracken forward and now at the
other end it's the turn score up to Donado he
goes forehand backhand on Joey dord he denies
and then next thing know shter on the boards
to Everly Everly finds Tatar and then Tatar
buries it on the stick side should have seen
the reaction of Joey dordon that boy was he
pumped up after that here comes Johansson in
to Gerard pass sh oh what a save by Len he
robbed goano Point Blank down the slot wow
sprawling lingren marvelous save on kagano
a little bit of a splits action there with
a his left P down for the one timer stop by
Ingram Oh Perfect and now it comes in front
and blocked away that was Nick fug stat oh my
kick save it a beauty by Big Nick get him on ice
bag Brandon Mator all both ja the delovic the
hot poker out of nowhere Alex the delovic with
a huge play with a has the puck out in front of
him like Montour you can't shoot it as a goal
tender that's a tell K right in put marrom maybe
got a to on that just enough for marrom with that
large frame of his he was able to get the pat on
boy what a great save that is I mean Mar got his
left skate blade on that one picked off by Trevor
Moore Kings get it and a shot right on rebound oh
what a save by huler on the rebound on fala his
best stop today Joel hord with a great save big
save by Joel hord look at that gets across here
to make the [Applause] save he's out of the box
and down the slot SK by gor oh my goodness he
stuck that LE pad out and he put the skate on
the post Kevin fiaa robbed out of the box F was
just trying to shovel that into the back of the
net must had three wax on it until Jack Johnson
ran him over at the crease what a safe byor holy
cow numers at the net waiting now to the net
rebound shot neighbors Rob by B leans oh what
a chance there the Blue's best chance tonight
from Jake neighbors great opportunity there
still don't know how that ended up staying out
of the net no ad doson at the line towards the
net right in front barcel what a stop and a follow
up as well Z LS that ball early two big saves with
Patrick W back of the building what a sequence
by montmo crowd [Music] buzzing hit a leaf and
gets Baron great here's Morgan Baron two and0
sov another STP and another oh did you see that
SS off two on0 and he holds the four you got the
fans on their feet now not just cheering that's
a standing o wouldn't he ever see a two on0 on a
short-handed three quick passes one save and then
somehow able to get that right pad and stay
anchored to make the save but an effort that
one drops it off Nelson round the net R try in
front stop sa got across and kept it out Corvette
nearly had his second you're right Brendon a good
stick save by sard as he's able to get in the way
that was a wide open shot comes away with it it's
a two-on-one he slides to Luke landing and scolls
out to make the save keeping the devils in it
temp the races two onone Devils lose the puck
and what a save on Glen Denning on the backand
it's m and Glen Denning he feeds Glen Denning
goes to the backand look A F of chick broken
sticks here on the trip behind the defense
oh big save there by terasoft keeping this a
two-goal game what a stop a terop with a couple
massive saves here and this is the biggest
one taks one to the Blue Line jws shot stop
garlands oh what a save by m leakin he reached
back with the paddle of the goal stick stopped
Conor Garland and covered the puck what a play by
Elvis to reach back there and lay that paddle on
the ice a short-handed break for szin moving
in stop rebound and a second save by reck oh
what a stop that second one was brilliant here's
a quick kitch in front one timer and a spring save
made by Skinner Bo evangelist is looking up with
the clock right now wants to take another look at
just cuz he can't believe this Puck didn't go on
the net Stewart Skinner with a good read makes a
save